The Joe Rogan experience, speaking of
which I was watching a video today.
You know how Youtube for whatever reason,
just starts recommending things and you
click on him watching a video today on,
oh,
this is what it was.
I was looking at bulletproof clothing
for whatever reason, cause I was like,
I saw an ad on Instagram where this
guy had a bulletproof hoodie on and it
looked like a regular
hoodie and he shot himself.
Is there like a John Wick situation
where it's like, yes, it's like,
it's like sewn in between
the fabric. Yeah. Yeah.
So this guy had a regular hoodie and he
shot himself in the gut with the a nine
millimeter just bang.
While while I was playing this video
with like a regular Hoodie, I was like,
this is crazy. And this Hoodie, it
looked like a regular hoodie was,
but it's some sort of Kevlar or something.
So then it recommends this next thing
and this next video that I watch is on
whether or not you should carry
with a bullet in the chamber.
So it's this guy who's
just speculating elected.
There's two kinds of people.
There's kind of people that thinks they're
going to have enough time to rack a
bullet. And there's a bunch of people
that realize that when something happens,
it's like being in a car accident happens
quickly and you gotta be prepared.
You're not going to have
enough time to rack a bullet.
And so there was this long discussion
as to whether or not you should have a
bullet in the chamber or
not when you conceal carry.
And he was talking about how
this guy was open carrying,
but he could see that the guys,
the hammer was shut down on the pistol,
which means he was going to have to
cock it cause it was a, a, a row,
not a revolver, but uh, you know,
whatever. Anonymous Semite what did,
what is it when the church,
what is it, when you call,
what do you call one of those when
you have to load it like that,
like a nine millimeter glock. What is
the difference? Well, one's a revolver.
A revolver revolves, so it's on a
revolver. It's just a pistol. Anyway,
he was saying because of
the way the hammer was, he
could tell that this guy, uh,
you know, he was going to
have to pull that hammer back.
He was going to use that
gun and I was like, this is,
this is like next level thinking
like these people, everywhere you go,
someone's worrying about shooting you.
And then I go on to Twitter
almost like this is synchronicity.
And Eric Weinstein,
who's a friend of mine says,
is this the the year where the debate
is something that in terms of is it
appropriate to bring a loaded gun into
a place where you worship now to protect
herself?
Because there've been so many attacks on
people and synagogues and churches and
mosques and I'm like, fuck man, what?
Probably what? What is happening
here? It's, I mean it's bad.
I don't, I'm not, I'm not like
a, there's two guns gun today.
What do you mean there's two more
attacks today at synagogues. It was,
one was in a church. What were
the ones that that happened today?
There was two smaller ones.
There was no,
there was the church that was in San
Diego this weekend? No, the, the uh,
the synagogue in San Diego this weekend.
But there was another one like this
morning when I was reading the News Los
Angeles? Yes. What was it for Mary?
26 year old US army soldiers servers.
Afghanistan has been charged with plotting
terror attacks in Los Angeles area,
a rally in Long Beach.
So I saw it's on the front page of CNN
already got something like it's some
sounds leaking through the video.
Did he do something or did
he just got caught plot?
It says he was accused of targeting Jews
as they walked to the synagogue police
officers. A military facility in
crowds at the Santa Monica pier.
I think there was another one too.
There was another one somewhere else
might've been outside the country today.
It's like fuck, like this
shit is ramping up. Yeah,
just getting worse and worse.
Are you a gun guy? I have guns.
I wouldn't say I'm a gun guy,
but I have them hunting or like I have
hunting guns and I have safety guns.
Like security, guns are private, you
know, personal protection guns. But,
um,
I hunt with a bow and arrow mostly,
but of course I'm not opposed to,
when I say of course being sarcastic,
I'm not opposed to it. What does this
California synagogue attack latest? Oh,
this is the, the, they found
the social media message,
I guess right before it happened.
Of course,
Jesus Christ you're
talking about? No, I dunno.
I think there was another one that I saw.
I believe it was in another country.
That's all right. That's enough.
There's so many. I know. I know.
You just numb to it. Well also that their
chart targeting places of worship now,
like what the fuck man?
Do you have guns? No. Would you ever
want one? They make me uncomfortable.
Like I'm not like against, people want
to have guns. Okay. I'm not done that.
It's not on the hill. I'm gonna die on.
But, uh, I think what's happening with,
with the schools and churches is a,
is reprehensible and it's,
we are the only country where this really
happens, you know, as much anymore.
It's happening, you know, uh,
around the world. But it's, it's,
it's much more often here.
Yeah. Yeah. Now there's,
there's certainly an argument for that.
The real problem is the guns are
already there. It's like how do you,
what do you do when you live in a country
of 300 plus million people with 300
plus million guns? Like how do you
ever eradicate that? How do you ever,
how do you shift the path
that we seem to be on?
Like what do you do? I mean
everything is like, you know,
people talk about this and then like, you
know, how do we do what, what's is it,
the culture is,
is this any,
he turned on the TV and it's like a video
game commercial or a commercial for a
movie and it's just a supermodel spinning
around in circles shooting everything
she sees you, you're like, you don't
think this has happened in effect, right?
Like they just make it look so cool
that if you want to be the hero,
you got to have a gun.
Yeah. How about John Wick?
John Wick three coming onto my fucking
favorite thing at her and I'm like,
this is the most, the most glorifying
gun shit ever. But I love it. I love it.
It is a problem. I mean, it hasn't
made me turn to guns, you know? I mean,
I wouldn't say that like
video games and you know,
make this video games or making
people more violent. I don't,
I don't believe that. I don't know if
there, there's evidence to back that,
but I mean, I've always loved, you
know, James Bond movies, you know,
things like where guns are are a,
are a big part of it and it's
never made me want to pick one up.
Well,
there's a real argument
that that alleviates some of
the need for violence that
people like seeing it and seeing
it and something like John Wick,
it actually relaxes people.
There's a real argument
for that and there's a real
argument that you could make
with that, with video games too.
But that is not with everybody.
The problem is certain people are
very susceptible to influence.
They're susceptible,
they're vulnerable to being influenced
or excited in one particular direction,
whether it's,
uh,
excited to become radicalized and become
a white nationalist, want to shoot up,
you know, um, whatever. Figure out that
whatever the group is or whether it's,
you know, there's certain
people that, you know,
they'll see something in a movie or a
video game and it'll make them want to act
that out, but they usually mentally ill.
I mean that's, that's a real problem.
The real problem is mental illness at
the type of person that could go into a
synagogue and just start shooting people.
That's a mentally ill person.
That's regardless of whether or not they
have a gun or not. That's a sick person.
So we have to figure out like what's
causing this massive amount of mental
illness in this country.
Cause that's a big,
that's the guy in Aurora is a
perfect example. That guy was,
they knew he was sick then they
knew there was something really,
I mean if you see the photos of that
fucking guy, you look at his eyes,
he was completely bat shit crazy.
Well, I think it's something to,
it's like when they, when they,
now they've started to refuse to show
the guy's face and they won't show it.
Like, this guy's getting glory now,
and the next shooter wants to top that.
But I think they're getting a little
bit smarter about it. But what's the,
what's the quote?
No Man chooses evil because it's evil.
They only mistaken for happiness.
Hmm.
Like, I believe that.
Yeah. That's a good quote.
Yeah.
They mistake it for happiness.
Or they want other people
to feel what they feel.
They want other people to suffer
the way they are suffering.
Yeah.
With,
I mean, w when you ever have a
giant country filled with people,
you're going to have a broad
spectrum of people's experiences.
And so you're going to have a certain
number of people that are on the low end
of experiences. The worst experiences all
the time, sexual abuse, physical abuse,
violence, mental illness,
pills, drugs, this, that,
boom.
[inaudible].